all right jasmine
yeah welcome back hi so it's it's been
quite a while
i posted your video recently but that
interview was actually from
probably the spring right yeah it's been
a while it's been quite a while yeah so
tell me what's going on in your life no
basically i'm still
like on the streets and whatnot um i had
a couple run-ins with
one of my my ex pimps or whatnot
i tried to work it out with him but it
got worse to where he was
choking me out to where i started
foaming at the mouth trying to kill me
threatening to go shoot my sister's
house where my daughter is
all type of stuff to where it was kind
of hard for me to leave him again
um and then finally when i got away
he'll show up to like different areas
that he knows i'm in
and he'll like hop out the car trying to
drag me in the car and threaten me and
all type of stuff um but
it took for him to go to jail for a
parole violation that's how
it stopped oh that'll do the trick yeah
so yeah
um but good for you yeah
your personality seems so
soft and sensitive kind-hearted and
and yet you're working this
hard life it's very hard cold it really
is heartless life
it really is you never know what we go
through you know a lot of people
you know don't understand you know how
do you
how do you survive i mean because you
don't seem as
thick-skinned as maybe some of the other
girls aren't to be honest i don't know
how i survive
i don't know um
just being out here and doing all this
stuff and i go through a lot of stuff
dealing with clients and i've you know
what i'm saying i still to this day i
don't know how to survive i'm look maybe
i'm lucky you know but
it gets scary sometimes because you
never know whose car you're going to get
in if you're going to make it out that
car you don't you never know you know
and that's the scary part of it
you know yeah i mean you're you need the
money exactly
because fast money easy money but like i
said it comes it comes with
consequences you know like um
you never know it seems to me like
there's no way
your soul can't take the hit doing this
kind of work
i don't believe humans are meant to just
right do this kind of work
like sometimes you eventually get
depressed or on drugs or something
yeah i'm not gonna lie like when i
started doing this and
not until i started showing and
everything like in order for me to go
outside and deal with the clients
i have to get high to numb that that
or like to number to deal with them you
know i couldn't go outside sober
or anything i had to get high yeah and
now that you're pregnant now mm-hmm
how far along are you i'm about three
four months
so using drugs while you're pregnant in
the beginning
before i was showing yeah i'm not gonna
lie um because it's hard
you know yeah it was crystal meth
but you stopped now i stopped yeah okay
yeah but like i said it's really hard
like so i would just numb it just kill
just to feel that feeling and to deal
with them i can't deal with
them sober do you tell me about your
your clients your customers are they do
you respect these guys
i mean to a certain extent i do but
some like for example i'm really sweet
um
and i get some clients that will be you
know kind of okay in the beginning they
end up doing
something dumb like trying to like one
guy had pulled the gun out on me and
took my money back and one guy
tried to stab me you know um
and i still try to go outside with a
good attitude and be nice and
you know but it's always that one that
will like you know have me think okay
all everyone's the same to where i get
scared sometimes but like i said i need
money so
i gotta deal with the consequences you
know of that
but yeah and then to quit this
line of work and and go get a a regular
job
nine to five job is that even a
possibility
now you're gonna be this is your first
child huh
do you have children i have four you
have four and you're raising
um they're not with me right now
[Music]
you're hoping to raise this one yeah i
do but it's going to take a lot
and and to get a nine to five job would
be
see the situation with me
as far as like you know you need
identification you need all that stuff
to
get jobs and all resume all that i don't
have any of that microden shows right
now because i wasn't born in the
hospital my mom had me at home
to where now there's no birth
certificate and i have to go through the
whole process of doing the labor of the
registration that takes a long time
to get a birth certificate it's a lot
you know and sometimes i just want to
give that's why i just do
do this because it's easier fast money
and
you know i don't got to go through the
run around
with it how much were you making tonight
it all depends on a good night
maybe two three hundred um sometimes i
won't even make that
on a bad night like a hundred sometimes
you're out there for a long time
it's just amazing yeah just to make a
hundred dollars it takes a very long
time sometimes you never know if you're
gonna really catch a date or
or anything i think you're the first
girl that's been honest yeah i'm just
being like yeah i have to
you know tell the truth you know some of
them say they're making 1500
stuff yeah i'm just being honest they
ain't no way in hell
whoever told you that they're lying it's
really hard out there
what what emotions do do you struggle
with the most you get
anxious or depressed or angry um as far
as
what like just i mean period i could
get i would get depressed if i get
depressed i am not gonna lie i do get
depressed um
a lot um i very suddenly get angry you
gotta really make me mad for me to get
angry but
more so depressed
yeah because i was like why my life had
to turn out like this but
you know you should have stuff happened
you know
so yeah what would you like to see her
i mean do you know who the father is of
your your baby
not really i'm just be honest and i
wouldn't put my business out there but
i'm just tell you the truth i really
don't know did that happen with one of
your clients
yeah so you you're having sex without a
condom
not necessarily a few times the thing
broke
and i didn't know at first you know
saying and then i got
like bigger and i i didn't know i had a
you know a little cycle i didn't started
seeing nothing of it but then i started
showing and i'm like oh yeah
pregnant so and i don't believe in
abortion so
yeah i'm ashamed but i'm not ashamed
you know what
what helps you survive this life i mean
there's
what do you tell yourself or what do you
how do you just you seem to be you like
if
i don't know you well but your
personality seems like man you this
this would really affect you in a major
way
what helps me
um like i said back then out
the ain't going like the drugs was
helping to numb it
and i just think about my future like oh
i'm gonna be getting i'm gonna have my
kids and this you know there's thoughts
like that because if you go outside with
a negative mind
it's not good you have no choice
yeah but yeah
and remember i refresh my memory
your childhood you had was there abuse
in your childhood it was
um a lot of abuse
like my foster mother she was the
ordained minister like i said and she
used to always tell me how i was going
to become a prostitute
oh that's right yeah how i was going to
die at an early age how my family was
going to disown me
and how dudes were going to beat me up
and ever since i left her home
everything's happened from being a
prostitute
coming close to death my family does
this on me i'm like the black child of
my family
and um i came close to deaf
a few times so yeah
it kind of paves the way for this
doesn't it
i've been shot in my face i've bug shot
to my face i've been stabbed twice
all type of stuff it's a horrible life
isn't it is
it's like i said it's scary like i've
had friends that i know
in the lifestyle that got killed like
got murdered all type of stuff
doing this and like i said you never
know
the heart the heart one of the things
that just hit me recently i mentioned it
in some of the other
talks with some of the girls i've done
recently that
just no just realizing that
every trick every
cop every other girl on the street the
temps that everybody that you're
interacting with
is on the take they're all up to no good
they're all kind of
interior motives ulterior motives just
they're looking out for themselves and
not you and nobody's really very much
yeah help you out and that's the part
that sucks because you think people are
your friends out here and it's like
they're not your friend they're just
it's there to see what they can get out
of you and when you don't got it then
that's
when they want to act funny and turn
their back on you and that's the part
that sucks
you know but yeah it's hard
very very hard i just try to be strong
and as much as i can but sometimes it's
hard for me to even do that you know
the world is cruel very very cool
is that how you see the world do you
have friends
i have associates i don't call everybody
my friend because
everybody ain't your friend you know
yeah yep
all right jasmine thank you so much for
coming in again and good luck with your
baby
thank you it's a crazy way for a
pregnant woman to be making money yeah
people will be looking at me crazy well
yeah
all right thank you
all right jasmine so we spoke a couple
weeks ago
yeah and i've been thinking about your
situation
a lot since then um
you have a baby coming i do yeah
and you're working the street yep and
you don't have any family to help you
with the baby when it comes
um i have found it but they're not
involved i don't get along with my
family
so you're really on your own and as you
explain that
the father of the child's not in the
pictures not at all
what stops you from getting off the
street and doing it
getting a job and um basically my
you know credentials that's why like my
birth certificate and stuff
um like when my mother had me she didn't
have me in a hospital she had me at home
and then i was taken to sentinel
hospital
but there's no record of it it's just a
paper that
my foster room had that said my mom's
name when i was writing how much i
weighed
but it's a copy but no one will take it
um
so now like every time i go to the
holler breakers they said that i don't
have a birth certificate and i would
have to go through the whole process
of doing the labor at the registration
but in the forums you need to
either they want me to put um the
location where my mom had me and i don't
know because my mom died in 93.
so as far as like knowing like where she
like for the exact apartment or anything
i don't know
so you're destined to work the streets
forever
unless you start unless you sort this
out yeah and it's been kind of
frustrating trying to figure it out and
then
calling around getting the runaround and
there must be some there must be some
solution to this that
yeah i tried and then it's i've tried so
many times where i get frustrated
you know and i want to give up you know
but it's a lot i have to do
so yeah so
you had a pimp at one point i did early
on in your career mm-hmm
is that what the tattoo on your forearm
is about yes it is
and he had his homeboy do it brand me
and of course i can't say no because if
i tell him no he gets mad and wants to
beat me up or you know so you were
forced to get that tattoo
it's big it is yeah i know i'm so
you're lucky some of the girls have it
on their face i know he was gonna make
me do it right here but
uh yeah he didn't he just had him do it
right here
yeah and you know how
how do they get you into that
relationship um
sweet talk or they act like they betray
like they're your friends
or like they just want to just kick it
or whatever and they sometimes trick
girls into
becoming their you know working um
prostitute or whatever
um it starts out cool in the beginning
and then it gradually gets into
oh you're gonna work for me or you know
trying to
you know get you into it it's kind of
weird so a typical night you would go
out in the street you'd make
a certain amount of money or a quota
right
how do you deliver it to them um just
basically like
text him or meet him on the back street
and and hop in the back seat and give
him the money
and then he'll drive off somewhere like
on another back street and let you out
again
and you give him all the money he'll or
if sometimes the guy search you they um
search if you got a new wig they'll pull
your wig off if you have it anywhere
else they'll
still search you it's called tucking so
yeah yeah
they don't like that
yeah that's so crazy and you're luckily
you got out your of you your situation
yeah he's enjoyed but a lot of girls can
no
some girls get killed by they pimp eat
every like a lot of girls we go through
a
lot
you never know like some dudes are real
crazy like i had a friend
her pimp killed her she wanted to leave
and it was all on facebook
so yeah it's hard sometimes
yeah so
you know i keep thinking about your
story since that last talk if i was to
somehow help you with some of your
expenses do you think you could
i mean i'm just i'm just trying to keep
the child keep you from losing the child
and maybe you can somehow
get your birthday birth certificate get
get your life together a little bit
does that sound like something you might
want to try yes but
especially with like stability that's my
main issue
yeah so i can help you a little bit
financially with that and then
yeah i'll do my part but you're gonna
have to do something work right i
appreciate
your end as well but uh i just i would
your story is just gonna this this
child's life is going to be sad if you
don't
get something together yeah and i don't
i don't want that you know
that's just the part that's going to be
like you know it's going to suck if i
don't get it together it's kind of hard
you know
being out here i think the honesty that
you sh you know you're
you're one of the most honest girls i've
talked to that works the streets
how to tell the truth it just made me
wanna
i think i think my viewers same thing
when someone's honest they like them
much more
they're much more easy it's better to
tell the truth about things and hide it
like if people want to not rather tell
them what we go through than
sugar coat or you know come up with
excuses for them like
i just want to be just truthful and tell
you the real uncut
everything about everything so yeah
all right so so we'll we'll we'll talk
further about how to do this but
i'll help you a little a little bit
financially here to
so you don't have to maybe you don't
have to work the streets so much or at
all
and maybe you can do some things that'll
prepare you for
i appreciate i think i mean i it helped
a lot that you told me you're not using
any longer and that
that's a big part of it yeah that's a
big part of it for me
thank you all right well
i wish you the best of luck thank you
all right well i guess we'll talk again
okay thanks joseph all right thanks
you